et on vient de la prendre le Conseil
d'État rejette l'interdiction
systématique des manifestations
propalestiniennes sur le territoire vous
le savez on en a parlé il y a quelques
jours dans TPMP le ministre de
l'Intérieur Géral Darmanin avait ordonné
l'interdiction systématique des
manifestations propalestinienes parce
qu'elles sont susceptibles de générer
des troubl à l'ordre publici c'est ce
qu'il avait
dit le ministre l'intérieur et saisi en
urgence par plusieurs associations le
tribunal administratif de Paris a décidé
jeudi de maintenir cette interdiction et
de
valider de donc donc euh de valider puis
ça a été retoqué par le Conseil d'État
ex ça et ça a été retoqué donc là
aujourd'hui c'est au cas par casà non ce
sera au préfet au cas par cas de juger
mais le systématisme a été considéré par
le Conseil d'État comme une privation de
liberté qui n'a pas lieu d'être et donc
chaque préfet quand il sera saisi d'une
manifestation devra trancher donc on
peut supposer que les consignes seront
éventuellement de les interdire mais
néanmoins monsieur darmana a été retoqué
sur ce fameux télégram qu'il avait
envoyé à la fin de sa trs bien interit
systé voà vous êtes d'accord ouais moi
je trouve ça très bien je trouve que le
Conseil d'État a eu raison il y avait
une sorte de systématisme qui était du
coup un peu stigmatisant et après tout
si une manifestation pourquoi une
manifestation serait forcément
catastrophique et il y aurait forcément
une apologie du terrorisme faisons aussi
confiance dans les proalestiniens et ils
peuvent peut-être manif après tout ils
peuvent manifester pacifiquement il y a
eu des manifestations dans le monde
entier et c'est vrai que nous en France
il y en avait pas et je pense que
c'était problématique il y avait
toujours cette notion de deux poids de
mesure de voilà nous pourquoi pas nous
et pourquoi ou oui pour les autres donc
faisons confiance et puis on verra bien
et si ça se pas mal ça se passe mal
pardon et ben on arrête voilà bravo
d'accord je suis entièrement d'accord
pourquoi la rue c'est toujours la rue
c'est là où s'exprime la rue al on
pourra pas dire aux gens vas-y tu peux
aller manifester pour ça pour ça pour ça
et là tu n'a pas le droit laissez-les
comme a dit Géraldine aller manifester
alleer ça fait du bien aussi peut-être
pour eux ça fait du bien d'aller dans la
rue s'exprimer parler entre eux ils
parlent ils s'expriment ils sont c'est
un drame ce qui se passe et puis si ça
se passe mal on dira on vous avez foutu
le bordel c'est fini on arrête mais tu
peux pas dire on manifeste pas
systématiquement sans avoir vu laissez
les faire ça fait peut-être bien à
certaines personnes peut-être aussi un
apaisement et moi je moi je suis pour je
veux qu'on je veux qu'on voie je veux
qu'on voie c'est très bien comme ça et
d'ailleurs dans les débats cy le Conseil
d'État puisquil était saisi en référé
donc il y a eu un débat et puis est
venue l'idée pourquoi est-ce que des
manifestations proisraélienne auraiit le
droit d'exister et pourquoi des
manifestations proalestinennes n'uraient
pas le droit fallait rétablir cet
équilibre qui était jugé asymétrique
donc ça a été une des motivations de la
décision alors je vous disais il y a un
instant c'est vrai que ce qu'on vit ici
vous avez énormément de de menaces vous
autour de la table notamment sur les
réseaux et je disais voilà que c'était
rien par rapport à à ce que V les les
populations
là-bas Jacques juste toi c'est c'est
c'est c'est la première fois que tu tu
as é dans un tel cas que tu sois autant
de menac autant de je voudrais pas
parler enfin je je je vais parler de moi
mais mais non mais c'est c'est c'est
c'est dingue parce que euh j'ai connu
des pays en guerre j'ai été menacé dans
des pays en guerre on m'a aussi brûlé ma
bagnole en banlieu pendant les émeutes
de 2005 où j'ai vraiment eu très très
peur mais là je trouve que le le le le
le climat et la façon de de menacer elle
me semble très tu nous parlais d'un d'un
gars qui était venu de voir aux abords
TPMP j'ai pas bien compris non c'était
pas aux abords TPMP c'était un peu un
peu plus loin j'étais en scooter il m'a
reconnu il a baissé sa vitre il s'est
arrêté devant moi m'a dit fais gaffe à
ce que tu dis sur la Palestine la
Palestine c'est pas ce que tu crois
voilà il était très menaçant et bon
c'est bon après il faut pas non plus je
pense oui oui voilà après je peux
comprendre aussi ces mouvements des
mouvements d'humeur et des mouvements de
colère moi j'en ai connu dans des pays
dans d'autres pays voilà j'ai vu un
caméraman se faire lycher devant moi à
péchawir juste après 2001 c'était une
époque où on brûlait les les les les les
drapeaux américains français et cetera
et nous on avait euh moi j'avais une
tête de français il se trouve que mon
cameraman il était un peu comme ton
invité tout à l'heure il avait il avait
une casquette il était il avait un look
un peu américain ils l'ont pris pour un
Américain et les talibans l'ont tabassé
devant moi ça a été une scène absolument
horrible donc les enfin voilà donc c'est
vrai que dès que tu dès que tu as une
prise de parole dès que tu as un rôle
entre guillemets dans les médias quel
qu'il soit bah il y a une menace qui
peut qui peut planer mais bon après il
faut aussi vraimon tu voulais non moi
depuis que je suis là j'ai toujours dit
j'ai toujours prené hein si tu viens à
faire de la télé faut pas pleurer après
qu'on t'inte sur les réseaux tu prends
tout tu prends les compliments et tu
prends les insultes et moi j'ai une
règle tu m'insultes je bloque je être le
mec qui a bloqué le plus de gens ici ça
doit être moi tu m'insultes j'ai plus
envie que tu me reparle je te bloque
j'ai jamais vu depuis 2012 je suis sur
Twitter c'est la première fois dans 10
ans c'est la première fois que je bloque
les conversations c'est jamais arrivé
c'est ve dire qu'avant je laisse les
gens répondre je m'en fous ils répond je
réponds et là j'ai bloqué quand sur le
le tweet sur Israël et le tweet sur la
Palestine j'ai bloqué sur les deux en
fait parce que des gens s'embrouillai
même entre eux c'estd dans la ation je
voyais passer des gens je crée de la je
crée des embrouilles moi je suis à
ClermontFerrand et moi je suis à
Strasbourg je vais venir t'égorger et
moi j'ai dis même monre vous c'est même
plus moi qu'on insulte donc déjà moi
qu'on m'insulte bon je m'en fous qu'on
menace de mortah c'est une chose je suis
à la télé mais des gens s'embrouillent
entrex c'est la première fois pour te
dire à tel point c'est une poudrière ce
truc à tel point c'est grave à tellement
on se on va voir que c'est très très
grave j'ai carrément bloqué les
conversations moi c'est jamais arrivé
tellement j'ai eu d'insult c'est au
moins des menaces de mort c'est
peut-être 200 300 c'est banalise pas
quand tu dis priv dès que j'ai fait un
tweet pour dire je condamne les
attentats en Israël ça a été au moins
500 300 500 j'ai arrêté je dis j'arrête
de regarder après tu fais un tweet en
soutien pour ce qui s'est passé à
l'hôpital de Gaza c'est pareil ouais tu
tweetes parce que Hanouna ton chien il
t'a demandé tu es le chien d'anouna il
t'a demandé de tweeter alors tu tweetes
ça alors mais sa une chose il me
demandera jamais même s me dit de
tweeter on s'est déjà embrouillé sur des
tweets en plus je vais tweeter le
contraire si me dit de pas le faire je
vais le faire quand même et j'enlèverai
pas de tweet non plus donc on s
embrouillé sur des tweets vraiment de de
merde hein plus mer demain tues PMP en
direct mais qu'est-ce que conard c'est
un
enregistré mais tu résumes tout en fait
ce ceux qui sont là-bas vraiment
souffrent nous faut se remettre en
arrière nous on allait acheter de
l'huile d'olive et du PQ quand il y a eu
le covid et les mêmes mecs viennent te
dire aujourd'hui oui soldat soldat
soldat de quoi soldat de quoi on t'a dit
qu'on ferme le pays qu'on te paye à
rester chez toi tu es parti chercher du
PQ tu t'es barricadé arrêter de donner
des leçons on connaî pas si'il l'a dit
on connaî pas le conflit on le connaît
pas juste moi j'ai jamais vécu ça en
fait c'est la première ouais mais je
t'ai senti je t'ai senti quand même je
te le dis mon Rimmon parce qu'on dit
tout ici et je t'ai senti affecté la
semaine dernière bien sûr d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que je t'ai mis au repos
tu as vu voilà tu besoin de souffler un
peu tu mas demandé tu me l'as demandé
oui ça gâche la vie ça gâche la vie
parce que tu peux pas être heureux si tu
vois des trucs comme ça tous les jours
et tu te sens concerné parce que tu
auras forcément des proches des amis
d'enfance qui vont te demander de
prendre parti et moi je l'ai dit j'ai
pas de camp il y a pas de camp il y a
pas de camp c'est c'est pareil c'est des
c'est des civils à chaque fois qu' vont
trinqué comme il a dit Bruno pomard et
moi la semaine dernière je t'ai dit
c'est très dur de venir à l'émission
parce que je me sens pas légitime parce
que j'ai pas le bagage parce que je ne
connais pas le conflit de A à Z donc je
vais venir mais mais j'étais très triste
je t'ai même dit ce weekend je t'ai dit
ça on est bien il il y a du soleil on
est là on va se promener mais ça gâche
les plaisirs en fait ça gâche les
plaisirs et j'ai jamais moi j'ai jamais
vu sur les réseaux autant de de haine
autant quand j'ai dit faut pas giffler
le Président je me suis fait insulter
autant ça c'est rien du tout on s'en
fout là c'est vraiment pour que
j'envienne un point de dire au g je ne
veux plus voir ni discuter j'ai tout le
temps discuté sur les réseaux moi avec
tout le monde j'ai tout le temps parlé
le plus que je pouvais là c'est c'est
c'est trop pour que je bloque les
conversations en 10ant c'est jamais
arrivé c'est jamais arrivé que je dis
bon c'est bon votre votre avis là gardez
votre avis voilà on va penser d'abord à
ce qui se passe là-bas et tes proches il
disent quo mais mais mais même des
proches des amis que je connais depuis
40 ans qui me disent j'ai des
conversations avec des amis de 40 ans
que je connais qui me disent ouais
comment tu peux comment tu peux
justifier comment tu peux tolérer j'ai
je ne tolère pas je justifie pas je
m'embrouille avec des mecs que je
connais depuis 30 ans il me dis ouais
mais maintenant tu as changé tu tu su
Souna mais tu me parles à qui là tu tu
ça fait 30 ans qu'on se connaît à qui tu
tu me connais par cœur décidément tu ne
me connais pas en fait et ça fait mal
parce que c'est des amis c'est des
proches c'est de la famille et à chaque
fois c'est où faut prendre partie c'est
très bien tu as pris parti pour Israël
tu es bien où tu as pris partie pour la
la Palestine tu es bien non non c'est
c'est on différencie le Hamas qui est un
mouvement terroriste et la population
palestinien j'ai pas de camp moi et et
en ce moment ça me blesse parce que il
n'y a pas de conversation possible c'est
ça qui est grave
tu peux pas faut forcment avoir unamp
c'est ça qui fait mal parce que qui tu
vas parler il vont dire mais pour qui
c'est pas un match de fout les mecs je
suis pour personne je suis pour la pêche
je pour je veux pas que des bébés se
fassent flinguer jeis pas pour qui c'est
oui si je vais voir PSG OM je suis pour
Paris mais c'est pas un match de foot en
fait vous êtes tar les gars c'est très
durim non moi je suis d'accord avec ce
que ce qu'a dit Raymond
Jacques oui alors moi effectivement
comme Raymond ça a été tellementf en
encore une fois mon petit cas personnel
on s'en fout et c'est évidemment
complètement dérisoire mais malgré tout
c'est vrai que l'ambiance elle est très
anxiogène elle est très malsine elle est
très délétaire pour la première fois
j'ai bloqué mes commentaires sur
Instagram parce que moi qui suis un
petit compte Instagram pas avec beaucoup
d'abonnés d'habitude j'avais 1200
commentaires et là j'en avais 3000 et
autant vous dire que les 3000 c'était
pas c'était pas sympa donc c'était
évidemment très violent très agressif
bon voilà CRZ là en quiipa des trucs
antisémites contre vous beaucoup contre
vous bizarrement toujours l'argent sorte
de délire comme c'est antisémite
insupportable donc il y a quand même des
relants moi qui alors tu dis oui on est
là en gros et comme on est à la télé on
a le droit de se faire insulter ouais
mais bon ben pas tout en fait non je
suis désolé pas d'antisémitisme
systématique les menaces ben non en fait
Raymond les menaces et les intimidations
il y a pas de raison en fait parce qu'il
y a des gens qui ont été menacés comme
Samuel paatti à la fin ben il est égorgé
donc en fait je vois pas pourquoi ce
serait une sorte de fatalité sous
prétexte que tu es à la lumière et et
dans dans sur un plateau télé qu'on
puisse te menacer comme ça en toute
impunité parce que tu as juste dit que
que la masse comme tu l'as dit très bien
et comme on l'a tous dit ici c c des
terroristes et qu'on voulait deux états
en paix en quoi nous on est dans le camp
du mal en disant ça donc c'est juste
insupportable et donc oui voilà l'époque
est est compliquée donc oui j'ai bloqué
mes commentaires mais c'est pas une
lâcheté de ma part c'est juste que je
trouvais que c'était juste stérile oui
Jean-Michel ouais non moi je moi je lis
toutes les critiques j'ai lis les
commentaires et cetera mais ça me sère à
chaque fois comme tu disais qu'il y a
pas de camp je crois malheureusement que
si tu es pas complètement hypocrite ENF
si on n'est pas complètement chacun
s'est quand même fait une idée quand
même dans sa tête a quand même choisi un
peu son camp mais alors que tu le veux
non tu as un peu choisi ton camp et moi
je le vois parce que quand j'essaie de
discuter de discuter d'essayer d'avoir
un discours un peu équilibré de parité
d'expliquer
le on entend rien c'est derrière tu as
quelqu'un qui pense d'un côté ou de
l'autre mais tu as jamais quelqu'un qui
pense comme toi et cetera donc un moment
c'est on te pousse à choisir quelque
part une partie plutôt que l'autre donc
c'est c'est ça que je trouve plutôt
affigeant et très triste sur l'avenir
pour l'avenir ah ça qui est c'est très
clivé je suis d'accord avec Jean-Michel
moi j'ai des centaines des milliers de
messages de gens qui me disent il faut
soutenir la Palestine il faut donc
j'essaie d'expliquer de dire mais moi je
ne soutiens personne je condamne
fermement le Hamas et euh je suis pour
que le peuple palestinien a le droit à
l'autodétermination mais je ne suis pas
contre Israël donc je suis d'accord avec
Jean-Michel en fait quand on essae de
rester sur une ligne de crête beaucoup
de gens disent mais euh tu n'es pas
courageux tu devrais tu devrais tu
devrais et et c'est très compliqué c'est
extrêmement compliqué c'est de
l'équilibrisme voilà moi j'ai du mal
voilà j'ai des des des encore une fois
des gens qui me disent mais défends
défends défends la Palestine défends la
Palestine moi je suis pas le porte-voie
de la Palestine j'essaie de de de
d'expliciter ce que je peux et encore
une fois d'être sur une ligne de crête
et et d'apaiser mais les gens sont
extrêmement moi j'ai peur tu eu des
menaces oui j'ai eu des menaces moi moi
j'ai peur j'ai j'ai
peur j'espère me tromper totalement et
ça n'engage que moi j'ai peur d'un d'un
embrasement de la société française moi
c'est ça ma crainte terrible terrible
quand je vois quand je vois la manière
dont les positions sont extrêmement
virulentes je ne vois pas de
réconciliation moi quand j'essaie
d'avoir un avis mesure bon allez c'est
bon tu es toi ah oui on croyait que tu
étais avec nous mais je suis avec
personne j'essaie d'expliquer et c'est
extrêmement clivé j'ai très très peur
dire je veux bien entendre mais je dis
pas que j'ai raison hein bien sûr vous
avez très très peur et ca pour l'instant
le conflit il est il est là-bas il est
extrêmement violent et il y a deux prof
qui ont été tués quand même donc
excusez-mo c'est a vrai mais comme on l'
dit et par exemple sur sur le terroriste
en
Belgique là je je pense que c'était un
gars qui voulait tuer des Suédois parce
qu'il avait il avait un problème avec
les Suédois
voilà c'est ça voilà mais c'est vrai que
bien sûr et on le sait il y a eu des
drames
encore mais c'est vrai que voilà on pour
l'instant euh voilà c'est vrai qu'il y a
on sent une tension énorme vous le
sentezv sur sur les réseaux et et cetera
mais c'est vrai que voilà la la le drame
il est il est là-bas et il est il est
quotidien il est il est de toutes les
minutes oui et cette cette tension la
sentait pas par exemple pendant le le
conflit en Ukraine les gens il disaient
pas ok on est pour l'Ukraine on est pour
la Russie tandis que là ce conflit là il
s'exporte en terme de murs en terme de
de de valeur en terme de religion ici et
c'est en train de fractionner parce que
effectivement on sentait quand même dans
les médias malgré tout faut le dire une
genre de pensée unique une genre de
bienéance qui disait que Ben quelque
part faut interdire les rassemblements
de Palestiniens alors que c'est aussi en
fait il y a pas de il y a pas de
victimes il y a pas il y a pas de
religion au niveau des victimes en fait
que ce soit des Palestiniens ou des
Israéliens voilà oui mais voilà ce que
je veux dire c'est que quelque part
inconsciemment on nous a tous demandé de
choisir un camp ce qui n'était pas le
cas pour les autres guerres jusqu'à
présent je rappelle le Conseil d'tat
rejette l'interdiction systématique des
manifestation euh propal et c un dernier
chiffre 2500 actes antisémite déjà
recessensé 2500 et ça faisait partie des
débats aussi c'est énorme et ça c'est
insupportable il faut totalement le
condamner